Scott Pilgrim vs. The World is a decade old, and
this ode to the aimlessness of young adulthood
still has a cult following. But
while the film is whimsical,
it also has its flaws. Here are aspects of
the film that take on new meaning for adults.
The very first line of the movie informs us
that 22-year-old Scott Pilgrim is dating a
high-schooler, the 17-year-old Knives Chau.
"How old are you now Scott, like 28?"
Even though the audience subsequently
learns that they haven't even kissed yet,
it's still icky, and only gets worse as you get
further and further from high school yourself.
"You're too good for him. Run."
Some of Scott's friends, to their credit, point
out that Scott is hiding in a safe, pressure-free
non-relationship in the wake of a bad breakup the
previous year. Others, however, are completely
fine with the idea, as Knives begins to attend
Scott's band practice and shows. His roommate
Wallace for some reason agrees to wait outside
Knives' school with Scott until the final bell
rings. At the film's end, Ramona even hints that
Scott and Knives should get back together. What?
"You two make a good combo."
In fact, the ending originally shot for the
film had Scott and Knives getting back together.
When that divided test audiences, it was revised
to Scott and Ramona starting over instead.
But speaking with Collider in 2021,
Edgar Wright , the film's director,
explained that even in making that adjustment,
"The key to it was that Knives lets him go."
"I'm too cool for you anyway."
So even now, the one-sided relationship that many
would say has all the hallmarks of an adult man
"grooming" a teenager is considered a legitimate
side of a love triangle? As the years go by,
that part of the movie gets harder to defend.
In a 2007 essay for the AV Club about the
movie Elizabethtown, pop-culture critic
Nathan Rabin coined a new phrase, saying,
"The Manic Pixie Dream Girl exists solely in the
fevered imaginations of sensitive writer-directors
to teach broodingly soulful young men to embrace
life and its infinite mysteries and adventures."
Within a few years, it became a widely-used term
to describe the many movies where a colorful,
lively young woman — like Kate Winslet
in Eternal Sunshine of the Spotless Mind
or Natalie Portman in Garden State — lures
a mopey male protagonist out of his shell.
I-I make a noise or I do something
that no one has ever done before and
then I can feel unique again, even
if it's only for like a second."
It's intriguing to consider in retrospect
whether Ramona Flowers conforms to this trope.
While she's a more detached, quiet character
than your bubbly Zooey Deschanel types,
she unfortunately fits all the other stereotypes.
She never appears in the movie on her own,
what glimpses we do get of her life are
only in regards to her past relationships,
and the movie never explains what
drew her to Scott in the first place.
So, in place of personality and character,
the audience gets a female lead who has lots
of exes and colorful hair — along with a
montage of people at a party telling
Scott cryptic things about Ramona.
"She's got some battle scars, dude!"
There is a relatively fun self-aware gag in
the movie about Ramona appearing in Scott's
dreams via a convenient subspace highway, which
is how she becomes the girl of his dreams. But
although Mary Elizabeth Winstead brings
admirable depth to the role with her performance,
as the years go by it becomes harder to not wish
there was more of a sense of who Ramona is when
she's not simply servicing Scott's story.
The way the LGBTQ characters are presented in
Pilgrim might set off different reactions in
focus groups today than it did a decade ago.
Wallace Wells, Scott's gay roommate, has an
active, seemingly polyamorous lifestyle. Which
is fine — even Scott doesn't mind
it, despite sharing the same bed.
"Hey, morning."
"Hey Jimmy"
"Double standard!"
But it seems like Wallace can't have a single
conversation without asking if boys go to Knives'
school, or pretending that the girl Scott is
referring to is a boy. From stealing Scott's
sister's boyfriend during a concert to watching
Lucas Lee film a movie because he's his crush,
it really is bizarre how every opportunity
Wallace has to speak turns into an opportunity
to reinforce his sexual identity. Keiran Culkin's
performance makes Wallace consistently amusing,
but revisit the movie again and you'll be
amazed at how one-note the character feels.
Roxy Richter, meanwhile, is
all but ridiculed as a phase
by Ramona when she's revealed
to be her fourth "Evil Ex."
Given no backstory or flashback other than
Ramona saying she was once bi-curious,
Roxy seems to exist just to
make some lesbian-related puns.
"Well honey, I'm a little bi-furious!"
Another strange aspect of Scott Pilgrim vs.
The World you might notice as you get older
and more worldly is its off-kilter relationship
with non-white characters. Matthew Patel,
the first of Ramona's Evil Exes,
is of Indian-Canadian heritage,
a fact that isn't terribly relevant until he
launches into a Bollywood dance number near
the end of his fight with Scott. The fifth
and sixth evil exes, the Katayanagi twins,
fall into the "silent Asian" stereotype that was
called out last year by Mulan actor Jimmy Wong.
Even Knives, while she gets plenty of lines and
time to shine as a character beyond her ethnicity,
is referred to in a strange, loaded
moment as Scott is talking to his friends.
"Knives Chau. She's Chinese."
"Wicked."
It's a small moment, but it plays into the larger
trope of fetishizing Asian female characters,
one that has come under fire in the
years since the film's release.
Scott Pilgrim is unemployed. He's also 22
and dating a high schooler in a strange,
sexless pretend-relationship. He shares
a studio apartment with another man,
who owns all of the furniture and the lone bed.
This studio apartment is across the street from
the house where Scott grew up. Other than
perhaps playing bass in an unheralded band,
there isn't much about Scott
Pilgrim that doesn't scream "loser."
Scott spends nearly the entirety
of the film's runtime acting whiny,
insecure, and selfish. He cheats
on his high school girlfriend,
then dumps her without explanation. He makes the
barest attempts at apologies and introspection
right before the film is over, but it's clear
he hasn't grown much by the movie's conclusion.
"Hey, hey, mind if I tag along?"
If they were to make a sequel, we'd most likely
discover ten years later that Scott is still not
nearly as cool as the original
film frequently made him seem.
Chris Evans has appeared as Captain America
in the Marvel Universe in 11 different movies.
It's hard not to imagine what comedic roles
he turned down to spend a decade in spandex
after re-watching his uproarious turn as
Lucas Lee in Scott Pilgrim vs. The World.
Beginning with the moment he cracks his neck
in time with the Universal Pictures fanfare,
Evans generates the most consistent laughs per
minute of any of the Evil Exes, or perhaps any
character in the film. Playing an absurdly aggro
movie star in a bit of self-parody, after his two
movie turns as a pre-MCU Human Torch in the Fox
Fantastic Four movies, Evans has perfect timing
in declaring that Scott Pilgrim is no competition
and throwing him into Toronto's iconic Casa Loma.
"Hi. Big fan."
"Why wouldn't you be?"
With Captain America now behind
him, Evans' sly turn in Knives
Out is hopefully just the tip of more
interesting, diverse roles to come.
Beyond whether she qualifies as a
"Manic Pixie Dream Girl" cliche or not,
Ramona Flowers has a frustrating lack of
agency in Scott Pilgrim vs. The World.
This feels all the more grating when
you grow up and realize how complicated
a good love story can be in movies
disciplined enough to properly develop
one. It's entirely unexplained why Ramona invites
Scott back to her place and makes out with him,
on a "date" that was explicitly pitched as
a platonic hangout. While the revelation of
the League of Evil Exes complicates her story and
explains some of her detached attitude, it's not
terribly clear how the League haunting her makes
her feel, other than as it pertains to Scott.
When she abruptly leaves Scott to return to her
ex Gideon, it's a bummer but at least a decisive
action that hints at deeper motivations. But even
that turns out to be telling someone else's story,
as Gideon has attached a mind-control device to
the back of her head, transforming her entirely
into a damsel in distress for the film's big
action climax. Adding insult to injury, she mostly
takes a backseat in the showdown with Gideon,
as Scott and Knives do most of the fighting.
Scott Pilgrim vs. The World was celebrated
upon its release for having an array of diverse
female roles. But in actuality, it fails
the standard-bearer test of representation
in cinema known as "The Bechdel test."
Named for cartoonist Allison Bechdel,
it goes like this: To pass the
test, a film must have at least
two female characters that talk to one
another about something other than a man.
Revisiting Scott Pilgrim vs. The World, it
never quite passes. Even when Ramona, Knives,
Envy or others make small talk with another
female character, it's always about Scott, Gideon,
or some other mutual male friend or ex-boyfriend.
The Bechdel test sounds so simple — give your
character enough depth to say something other
than a line that advances the male antagonist's
story! — but in films like Pilgrim, it is
apparently impossible to imagine these female
characters having their own distinct lives.
As adults, it's easy to be hard on an unemployed
loser like Scott Pilgrim. As it's a coming-of-age
story, you might say he's supposed to be a loser
in the beginning. Surely he grows and changes
over the course of the film? In a word, no.
Scott spends the majority of the
film as a self-centered, entitled,
whiny and defensive character. When he
reluctantly admits to Knives and Ramona
that he cheated on both of them, he at
last has an opportunity to act mature,
but Gideon stabs him in the back,
killing him. In a video-game twist,
an extra life that Scott earned earlier allows
him to come back and replay the final fight
again. This time, he gets a brief monologue
where he reveals to Knives and Ramona that he
cheated on them voluntarily, but still doesn't
have to deal with any significant consequences.
"So are we all good?"
"Never felt better."
In this final sequence, the first time through,
he fights Gideon with a sword he earned through
the power of love, but on the second pass he earns
it through the power of self-respect. This makes
no sense, because Scott has demonstrated that
if anything, he has too much self-respect. Is
there a sword you earn by respecting the women in
your life? Because Scott needs to earn that one.
Scott Pilgrim vs. The World is
largely a video game-inspired fantasy,
so maybe it's not fair to hold it to a coherent
standard in terms of today's gender politics.
But the older you get, the more you start to
realize that the League of Evil Exes is more than
just a framework to structure the story around
— it's toxic masculinity in its purest form.
Without much nuance or backstory, the
fighting in the movie reduces dating
to a tournament where Ramona is the prize,
objectifying women as objects to be fought
over instead of human beings with
willpower, thoughts and feelings.
While this is partially the result of distilling
a six-volume graphic novel into a two hour film,
it ultimately creates something that's fun and
flashy, but reduces gender roles to a digital
binary: men are stoic warriors, while women are
princesses in towers to be claimed as rewards.
With the exception of Michael Cera, virtually
every member of the cast of Scott Pilgrim vs. The
World was more or less on-the-rise, and has seen
their careers blossom in the years since. Looking
back now, you see Aubrey Plaza before Parks and
Recreation, Chris Evans and Brie Larson before
the MCU got them, Anna Kendrick before Up in
the Air and Pitch Perfect, and the list goes on.
But when the film hit theaters in 2010,
the consensus seemed to be that Ellen Wong
had stolen the show as Knives Chau and
seemed poised to be the film's breakout.
In the years since, Wong has worked
steadily, playing a semi-prominent
supporting role on Netflix's GLOW for
three years before its cancellation — yet,
the Ellen-Wong-mania that seemed about to
materialize a decade ago never quite went
down as planned. Looking back now as an adult,
perhaps it's time to once again appreciate her
performance — and seek out some of the smaller
roles she's capably filled in the years since.